[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
de continua escuchamos noticias sobre el
tránsito de miles de personas alrededor
del mundo en busca de un lugar seguro
para vivir un nuevo país que les brinde
las garantías suficientes para un
presente y un futuro tranquilo pero poco
se habla de lo que pasa cuando un
migrante o refugiado llega a su lugar de
destino allí son múltiples los desafíos
que trae la acogida y de la forma en la
que se desarrolle su proceso de
integración dependerá en gran parte su
contribución al país que ahora los
recibe al final un vínculo que
contribuirá al desarrollo a continuación
dos historias que dan cuenta de esto
tiene nueva alcalde este pueblo en
Alemania eligió por una amplia mayoría a
Ryan alsheph como su nuevo dirigente un
hombre de 29 años que no nació aquí
en 2015 vine a Alemania en ese momento
como solicitante de asilo
ahora es ciudadano alemán pudo aprender
el idioma y estudiar administración
con mis padres la alegría era enorme
para ellos también fue inesperado ya
sabían que yo estaba haciendo campaña
aquí que no tenía mucho tiempo para
ellos pero no creo que realmente
esperaran que yo ganara las elecciones
Y aunque Todavía no se ha posesionado en
el cargo el apoyo hacia él y su historia
es positivo
es bueno cuando las personas se integran
cuando llegan aquí de tal manera que
también pueden afianzarse en profesiones
que preocupan al público Y sí si los
ciudadanos lo encuentran capaz Entonces
sí es absolutamente la decisión correcta
al chef es el primer alcalde de origen
sirio en el suroeste del país
también en Alemania otro sitio espera
hacer historia husain comenzó a jugar
ajedrez cuando tenía cuatro años ahora
con 11 hará parte del equipo nacional
alemán que competirá En Croacia empecé a
jugar muchos torneos en Alemania y así
mejoré mi alemán Así es como quizás hice
más amigos
el ajedrez lo aprendió de su familia su
padre comenzó enseñándole las bases del
juego y pronto se dio cuenta del talento
excepcional de su hijo
estamos muy orgullosos de que jusaina
haya sido invitada a unirse al equipo
alemán para participar en torneos
internacionales deseamos que el equipo
alemán logre buenos resultados este
éxito será para Alemania pero también
para husaín
y su familia tienen un estatus temporal
en Alemania por dos o tres años más y se
preguntan Qué pasará con ellos cuando
ese tiempo termine
estoy bastante seguro de que todos aquí
quieren dar una contribución para hacer
de este un país en el que valga la pena
vivir a menudo pienso que es una lástima
lo difícil que es y los muchos
obstáculos para que personas como ellos
obtengan reconocimiento se sientan como
una parte de nosotros aquí
husaín ha ganado varios campeonatos
representando a Alemania entre ellos el
mundial sub 12 en 2022
esas historias fueron posibles gracias a
programas que le permitieron a los
recién llegados participar activamente
en la vida del país que los acoge pero
también fue primordial la forma en la
que fueron recibidos y aceptados por la
comunidad en Estados Unidos una
iniciativa Busca extenderles un mensaje
de bienvenida Esta es la historia
[Música]
Paty y su nieta hada dejen una manta
para un receptor especial
Esta es nuestra nota para los nuevos
inmigrantes que han llegado al brooklyne
hemos hecho una preciosa Manta para ti
de parte mía y de mi nieta Bienvenidos a
brookline nuestra familia vino de Europa
del este para evitar los prejuicios y
vivir libremente
un regalo que cuenta parte de su
historia familiar y que será entregado a
alguno de los migrantes y refugiados que
llegan a esta localidad de Massachusetts
como ellas varias personas preparan
frazadas similares en un proyecto
nacional
tenemos unas 30 más de 30 agencias de
reasentamiento en todo el país con las
que colaboramos
una vez terminadas las empaquetamos y
las entregamos a esas agencias para que
las regalen a inmigrantes refugiados o
solicitantes de asilo que vienen a
Estados Unidos
son mantas que entregan un mensaje de
acogida y que nacieron como una forma de
protesta en rechazo al discurso de
Donald Trump hacia la inmigración
trato de diseñar las mantas y las tejo
con la idea de que alguien básicamente
se cura y se sienta cálido y que
sostenga a alguien y les dé un abrazo y
los mantenga calientes
el proyecto ha llevado un mensaje de
bienvenida hasta Atlanta Chicago Los
Ángeles y Vermont Ay Dios mío me encanta
se sienten tan especiales y ya sabes
esta fue parte de estos proyectos y
estoy tan feliz de tener una de ellas
los activistas que impulsan Welcome
blanket esperan que esta iniciativa se
convierta en una tradición en Estados
Unidos
según la organización internacional para
las migraciones una integración acertada
es un proceso de doble vía que implica
una adaptación de parte y parte tanto de
la comunidad de receptora como de los
migrantes refugiados o solicitantes de
asilo y que al final resulta en la
construcción de sociedades más fuertes e
inclusivas
hasta que inmigrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante cf24
siga con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]